yo if someone comes to the Bay you're
visiting
what's the advice so they don't get bit
are we like you land you get your rental
car you got all your luggage let's say
I'm hungry I'm gonna eat am I taking all
the luggage out of the car putting it in
a restaurant with me most definitely
okay
when you pull up roll your windows down
roll all the windows down you know most
people pull up and be like roll the
windows up we're getting out no when you
pull up roll the windows down
I don't care what the weather is but
roll the windows down okay and take
everything out of your car
don't risk it the great advice is go to
the room first or go to your Airbnb put
your stuff up don't leave
don't leave us a Safeway bag in the bags
don't leave nothing
a [__] charger nothing because what
happens is they identify the cars and
they're like oh that's a rental they
know so they know it's a rental like
it's a science to it right so it's a
rental like oh he got a brand new
Chrysler 300. oh we got him we got a
rental and then people be thinking this
is the biggest reason why most people
get bipped those hazards
um those hazards let a person know that
you coming right back to the car
so
it's evident that you've left something
in the car since you're coming right
back that fast
that's a red that's a hey something's in
here that's a green light yeah we yeah
because it happened so like you could go
you could go to that door to the front
door right here
the bit pulls up so fast
by the time you get back here you like
oh
oh so hey yeah man roll your windows
down you come to the Bay Area roll your
windows down you're not safe don't think
just because you're going into Starbucks
and anything like that you are not safe
roll the windows down you will be highly
disappointed just allow them to open the
door and go through it man and there is
nothing that there's no chain of command
so you can't call the big homie you
can't call the rapper to be like man can
you get my stuff bro that's gone it's
probably some 14 year old 15 year old
who don't even know who your big homie
is he don't know nothing it's no
protocols no chain of command it's none
of that this is get it how you live they
eat you feel me they out are the Kia
boys eating out there right now because
in La there's just a lot of little kids
stealing Kias with USBS right now man
that's all kind of stuff you got the
Scat Cat boys the Hellcat cause you know
they got the whole you know the bay is a
little bit more technical
technologically uh technologically
advanced it's Silicon Valley so it's
some silicon game going on there's some
pull up to your car with the iPad
reprogram the Hellcat we'll get the key
God wait so what do they do man you got
the reprogrammer so you got to when you
get in the car you got to reprogram it
putting it under the thing reprogram the
key
Boop started up it's serious
that's amazing it's a whole different
level of uh a similar thievery going on
out there someone will disable your key
on God and bring a new key and just
reprogram it that's impressive the
youngsters says man they Advance that's
why I'll be telling us like dude y'all
taking all this time for Crime imagine
if you did something positive with it
like imagine if you created the
anti-program where now you can
deactivate somebody that's trying to
program like you can win be smart use
your talents for a great like you're out
here reprogramming vehicles in a very
hot in a highly stressful situation with
a very small amount of time you can work
on something different bro you're
getting a lot of stress you could be
diffusing bobs for the FBI come on man
you got talent kid yeah 14 year old 15
year old Kitty like
um then the way he explained it to you
is so funny uh all you gotta do bro take
the iPad put it under the thing when you
get the key boom it's gonna pop up the
app is gonna show up so then you
reprogram it right then you got about 90
seconds once you you get it you click it
boom then you you get up out of there
and then you're gonna take it to the
Mexicans the Mexicans gonna give you
three four thousand for him bro just
chop it down oh crazy bro that's amazing
so y'all I got too much time when you
say I'm on my brand that's all I be
looking for bruh I'm either gonna bip or
give me a Hellcat brand I know I could
go give me a quick three four thousand
dollars real fast bro say bro y'all it's
crazy bro stay away from the hellcats
for real hellcats and scats you will get
reprogrammed man
we could get you too huh bro your Lambo
that's not safe bro let me see this key
oh yeah I can reprogram this one I could
reprogram this right you got to be cool
leaving your key in the car huh
that [__] is crazy